qu'est ce que vous faites pour
l'environnement personnellement si vous
regardez votre voisin à droite ou à
gauche qu'est ce que lui fait pour
l'environnement si je vous pose cette
question comment vous sentez général on
sent un peu mal aux yeux je n'en fais
pas assez je trie mes déchets j'ai quand
même pris mon vol pour easyjet
mais on sent quand même pas très bien il
ya un petit côté culpabilisateur à dire
oui je sais je devrais en faire plus on
n'est pas très à l'aise avec ça comment
ça se fait que l'environnement soit
quelque chose de fantastique
et quand je vous pose la question qu'est
ce que vous faites pour l'environnement
puisque moi je fais pour l'environnement
on sent un peu culpabilisé cette
question je me pose et j'aimerais
explorer avec vous ces prochaines
minutes
l'écologie en fait c'est tout simple
donc c'est tout depuis 40 ans en gros on
sait que quand on détruit en écosystème
c'est pas réversible
prenez l'exemple du sucre et de l'eau si
vous avez du c'ur de l'eau voulais
mélanger il faut une seconde pour les
mélanger après je vous dis va rechercher
le sucre qui est dans l'eau maintenant
bah c'est pas aussi simple et ben quand
on peut lui une nappe phréatique et
quand on prend du pétrole et qu'on le
met en co2 dans l'atmosphère c'est la
même chose c'est pas réservé réversible
rhinocéros blanc est mort il est mort
fini si on n'agit pas ça coûtera
beaucoup plus cher de s'adapter au fait
qu'on a continuent à polluer imaginer
c'est tout simple un agriculteur mais
des fongicides comme ça arrivait à
fribourg dans un champ en pole une nappe
phréatique
peut-être pour les 100 prochaines années
on va devoir payer la purification de
l'eau et cette nappe phréatique est
foutu peut-être ça coûtait 50 francs ou
100 francs ne pas utiliser ce produit et
ça coûte et peut-être en millions ou 5
millions de purifier l'eau sur les cent
prochaines années
donc le fait de ne pas agir coûte
beaucoup plus cher que d'agir en suite
de ça l'écologie est le grand système et
l'économie et le petit système
on pense souvent oui bah en fait de
l'économie avec l'argent qui reste on va
déjà faire des mesures environnementales
en fait c'est faux c'est facile si vous
me lâcher à poil sur une île déserte
tient bon écosystème avec mes ongles et
mon cerveau je vais arriver à vivre très
bien je construit des maisons tout va
être possible si maintenant je vous
laisse où on me lave sur mars avec 20
litres d'oxygène
je vais pas pour faire une économie de
marché là bas aucune chance donc c'est
assez simple à comprendre que sans
écosystèmes n'y a pas d'économie et puis
enfin la barrière biologique sans
biodiversité
on n'a pas de soldes on n'a pas de
nourriture sans biodiversité on n'a pas
de fort et on n'a pas d'eau potable sans
oiseaux on n'a pas de protection contre
les insectes contre les bactéries contre
les maladies pas d'écosystème pas de
protection contre les maladies
pas de possibilité de produire de la
nourriture en fait voilà je vous ai fait
en cours d'écologie en une minute
c'est super facile la question qui se
pose comment ça se fait que la plupart
d'entre nous - vaquin vraiment on
regarde nos actes quotidiens et on le
regarde tous cette grille là pour se
rend compte qu'en fait 90% de nos actes
correspondent pas du tout à ce qu'il
faudrait faire
et là j'ai une petite explication et
c'est ça que j'aimerais développer avec
vous pourquoi premièrement si je mets
sur google donc dieu mec cool je me mets
coule sur google qu'est ce qui sort
xzibit pimp my ride lui il est vraiment
cool
il faut que tout sur la planète il a des
peines trop cool
il écoute en bon hip hop xzibit s'engage
super cool et si maintenant je mets
écolo qu'est-ce que j'ai fait google ans
pour moi j'ai un mec super chiant dans
le vocabulaire est résistance activisme
lutte ou alors moi je rentre du boulot
je suis fatigué j'ai envie de me
détendre un peu est ce que je vais
mettre le mec là la télé où je vais
mettre un bon pimp my ride
objectivement le capitalisme hyper cool
et les écolos sont super chiant ça fera
deux matches et écolo donc j'ai tout
problème à le dire mais c'est la vérité
c'est comme ça regardez le kit verbal de
l'écolo trois choses trois éléments qui
ressortent toujours les politiques
doivent comprendre il faut du changement
sinon le second va mourir
la mondialisation responsables de tous
la chine sera il nous faut de la
décroissance
en fait ces argumentaires vous pouvez
les cassée en trois minutes tu me fais
un plaisir de le faire est démontré
qu'en fait c'est pas du tout le coeur du
problème
les politiques doivent comprendre cela
sous-entendrait en fait que les
politiques sont les abrutis et puis que
le peuple lui les gentils puis on est
manipulé par les politiques qui ne font
pas les bonnes décisions
parce qu'ils sont touchés par des
lobbyistes parce qu'ils sont corrompus
et c'est avec nous le bon peuple on
serait si on était à leur place et ben
en fait on vit dans une démocratie
directe
et puis je pense la suisse pour ça un
très bon exemple dont les écolos devrait
vraiment s'inspirer à travers toute
l'europe
regardons à chaque fois qu'ils aient un
projet de loi qui a fait et combien de
fois il appartient aux référendums il ya
quatre super bon exemple en suisse
c'était des politiques cantonales qui
ont dit on va arrêter les chaudières à
mazout dans un délai de dix ans alors on
a en prime de climat on a du co2 qui est
émis par les chaudières à mazout on ne
peut pas résoudre le problème climatique
en continuant à utiliser du mazout donc
ils ont dit dans leurs projets de loire
on se donne dix ans pour gentiment
arrêté de remplacer des chaudières à
mazout par des chaudières mazuch super
simple comme projet de loi quatre
référendums quatre fois les projets ont
été abandonnés dans deux cantons romands
deux comptes en suisse allemand c'est à
dire que les politiciens dans bien des
domaines sont plus en avance que le
peuple et au peuple si on lui dit tu
préfère avoir un changement climatique
ou bien tu as chaudière à mazout dit moi
je veux ma chaudière à mazout
c'est comme ça la mondialisation
responsable oui oui il se trouve que
quand on est homo sapiens a quitté
l'afrique pour aller en australie vert -
quarante-cinq mille ans avant
jésus-christ il lui a fallu à peu près
2000 ans pour défoncer la majorité des
écosystèmes australien défoncer une
bonne partie de la microfaune étrangers
tous les équilibres écologiques de l'
australie en 2000 ans on n'avait pas
l'écriture on n'avait pas la roue on
n'avait pas de science on n'est pas de
panneaux solaires on n'avait pas de
chaudière à mazout
on n'est même pas l'agriculture pourtant
homo sapiens était déjà capable de
défoncer des écosystèmes la plus grande
déforestation d'europe c'est moins 1500
par rapport à maintenant donc plus 500
jésus-christ c'étaient les vikings en
islande 95% de l'islande déforester
c'est juste des mauvaises pratiques
qu'on véhicule de plus en plus et là on
est au bout du système
parce qu'on est au niveau planétaire et
surtout parce qu'on a des outils de
travail beaucoup plus puissant et comme
disait le pape on a développé des
technologies mon n'a pas développé
l'éthique qui nous permettrait
d'utiliser de ces technologies
donc on l'utilisé à mauvais escient et
on défonce tout et la mondialisation
injuste en accélérateur mais n'a rien à
voir avec le problème de fond c'est
comme au sapiens n'est pas capable de
gérer ces écosystèmes et puis il faut de
la décroissance
assez d'accord je pense que c'est assez
logique de dire que si on mange des
tomates en hiver qui viennent de l'autre
bout du monde qui ont été faits sous
serre avec du gaz
il ya probablement un problème
environnemental et ça peut pas continuer
comme ça mais de l'autre côté la
décroissance ne permettrait jamais à 7
milliards de personnes de vivre sur la
planète
la faute clair sans technologie on ne
peut pas avoir sept milliards de
personnes qui ont de la chaleur de la
nourriture et une mobilité minimum c'est
impossible on a besoin de technologies
on a besoin de fenêtres triple vitrage
on a besoin d'énergie
même pour un vélo il faut déjà un cadre
en aluminium il faut de la haute
technologie puisqu'il faut de
l'électricité pour faire de l'aluminium
pour faire avancer en train c'est
incroyable de technologie ce qu'il faut
il faut des terres rares et ainsi de
suite
donc la pure décroissance n'est pas
possible il faut de la décroissance bien
sûr mais théorie de la décroissance ne
fonctionne pas si on veut nourrir 7
milliards d'individus
voilà j'ai bien qu'assez de l'écolo je
vous dire j'ai beaucoup de potes
particules poids devant des français
après cette soirée
mais n'empêche vous rendez compte que ce
kit argumentaire en fait ne convainc pas
on dit oui il ya un problème
tout le monde est d'accord n'est en
faite par ces solutions là on se sent un
peu mal à l'aise ça donne pas envie de
passer à l'action et puis on se dit bref
pendant là qui causent les colos ville
écolo c'est le mec qui reste au bout de
la table
et puis qu'on écoute jamais parce qu'il
est toujours en train de râler au bout
de la table parce que cet argumentaire
est fondamentalement fausse le problème
n'est pas là la deuxième chose qui nous
encourage à ne pas avant aller de
l'avant c'est le quatrième pouvoir
alors je peux aussi critiquer chez écolo
et je travaille dans les médias donc je
peux moto flageller ce facile et je veux
offenser personne les médias comment
agissent les médias aujourd'hui sur les
thématiques environnementales
les écolos pour moi c'est les premiers
créateurs d'opinion et les deuxièmes ses
deuxièmes créateurs d'opinion c'est les
médias
c'est vraiment les deux groupes
principaux qui forment notre idée notre
vision de l'avenir c'est vraiment ces
deux groupes là que dit le deuxième pour
moi le 4ème pourvoir est complètement
dans l'ornière
actuellement les médias n'arrivent pas à
traiter de la question environnementale
et font énormément de bruit ça
s'explique aussi par plusieurs raisons
il ya une espèce de règles
journalistiques qui veut une neutralité
journalistique
donc on va dire si andy à l'autre doit
dire b et puis moi je suis journaliste
au milieu je vais équilibrer les propos
je suis au milieu on voit par exemple
sur le climat à chaque fois qu'on parle
de climat on doit inviter un climato
sceptiques
ah oui il ya quelqu'un pro climat ont
d'avoir un climato sceptiques comme ça
s'est équilibré
il se trouve que les scientifiques
climato-sceptiques donc des gens qui ont
des bases scientifiques qui sont des
climato-sceptiques 1 1 200 et 300 en
europe
des scientifiques qui sont pro climat
n'a peut-être un deux et dix millions en
europe
et ben si on fait le ratio de combien
publication médiatique en pro rata de
ces scientifiques
on se rend compte que la visibilité
donnée aux climato-sceptiques et
complètement exagéré et les très bonnes
études là dessus
le rôle du média s'est pas de dire andy
pleut et l'autre dit il fait beau c'est
de se lever et bouger ses fesses ouvrir
la fenêtre
regardez quel temps et fedor ça c'est le
travail des journaux c'est pas de dire
il pleut ou il fait beau j'en sais rien
chacun son opinion
la deuxième chose qui est très
importante c'est qu'on va lire en page
une catastrophe climatique problèmes
climatiques l'ours blanc en train de
mourir
raismes rédactionnelles je passe la page
2 les résultats de la formule 1 mais
c'est incroyable le nouveau bébé x 5m
motorsport v8 600 chevaux mais quelles
sensations de conduite
ça c'est ce qu'on lit en page 2 il ya
aucun choix rédactionnel qui est fait
sur ce dont on parle et ce dont on parle
pas je vais prendre deux choses qui sont
très impopulaires mais si je parle la
pédophilie est ce que quand on parle
d'un marche blanche
on va dire où il faudrait quand même un
pédophile qui nous disent
un petit peu son opinion histoire
d'équilibrer le débat et puis d'avoir un
article sur la vie du pédophile et puis
en arctique sur la maman de marche
blanche
bien sûr que non on prend des décisions
c'est le cas sur l'alcool c'est le cas
sur les drogues c'est le cas sur la
fumée pourquoi est ce que aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas le cas sur l'environnement
comment un média peut dire en aidant une
catastrophe environnementale et faire la
promotion du dernier véhicule polluant
avec une neutralité journalistique
parfaite et le troisième truc c'est que
les médias sont bloqués dans leurs
modèles économiques comme toutes les
autres entreprises
je vais faire un super article sur
l'écologie qu'est génial présenter des
initiatives positives et prendre une
petite publicité de gaz naturel qui va
dire l'énergie sofil c'est super
l'énergie fossile c'est bon pour le
climat 7 au super up et puis j'engage
l'argent c'est très difficile de sortir
de cette ornière pour les médias
aujourd'hui
mais c'est des décisions qui se prennent
les médias ne vont pas recevoir d'argent
des pédophiles ne sauve pas de l'argent
de la drogue ne reçoivent pas d'argent
de l'alcool et ben pourquoi pas en
matière d'environnement
c'est vraiment pas simple mais cette
question a le mérite d'être ouverte et
discuter le gueut maintiennent en
angleterre a fait ça le temps est en
train de changer sa pratique justement
ces réflexions sont en cours mais en
fait si on regarde objectivement
aujourd'hui j'ouvre le métier en média
le dimanche matin je vais vous lire du
pour et du contre du pur du contre et
puis dans ma tête il ya qu une soupe
molle de légumes broyé et reste plus
rien j'ai aucune idée de ce que je dois
penser aux ce que je dois faire
on a des articles contre le bio on est
des articles congrès attenberg on est
des articles contre le réchauffement
climatique pour le réchauffement
climatique et je fais quoi
objectivement je fais quoi je sors mon
p'tit déj fait quoi j'ai aucune idée de
ce que je dois faire et en fait c'est ça
que j'ai envie de vous raconter
aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire qu'on
devrait raconter
puisque les gens qui devraient façonné
nos cerveaux nos idées notre vision de
l'avenir
à mon avis le font très mal aujourd'hui
excusez moi mes amis je vais me faire de
foncer on devrait réfléchir à comment
est-ce qu'on devrait envisager l'avenir
et puis on a un peu c'est carrefour du
chemin si on prend pas la bonne décision
maintenant comme vous le savez ce serait
trop tard plus on attend plus on aura de
choses détruites est ce que je veux vous
montrer c'est le chemin peut-être à
droite qu'on peut prendre qui est très
facile à prendre
je vis aujourd'hui dans une maison
autarcique elle était construite en
paille en terre elle n'est pas raccordée
au réseau d'eau elle n'est pas raccordé
au réseau d'électricité
elle est 100% solaire
on utilise à peu près deux stères de
bois par année et c'est tout notre hôte
pluie et nettoyées on boit notre eau on
a un jardin qui re nature et on a des
dizaines d'espèces d'oiseaux qui
reviennent on a des centaines d'espèces
de végétaux la maison vie par elle même
j'ai plus de coups et nager j'ai plus de
coûts de chauffage et plus de coûts
d'électricité j'ai plus de coups d'eau
j'ai plus de coups de mobilité ma
voiture électrique la charge par ma
maison j'ai augmenté mon pouvoir d'achat
énormément grâce à cette maison et en
plus elle est superbe on a une qualité
de vie magnifique on va se baigner dans
la piscine naturelle qui a pas de chlore
qui a pas de pompe juste nettoyées par
les plantes et c'est une qualité de vie
qui est absolument magnifique
voilà la personne qui m'a acheté qui ne
m'a vendu la charpente c'est à ce
monsieur que je donne l'argent en
construisant ma maison donc là vous
voyez ma charpente précisément voilà mes
murs c'est pas du pétrole vient de chez
paou c'est pas des briques qui vient de
se passer c'est les murs de la maison
que vous voyez derrière et l'argent que
j'ai donné à ces gens dans une économie
locale courte circulaire avec des
matériaux biosourcés et puis ça c'est
des légumes de nos jardins de ce la
semaine dernière sans arroser sans
pesticides sans herbicides sans
fongicide sans rien on plante on oublie
en récolte 0 travail ça c'est la
permaculture
il y avait des périodes de sécheresse on
n'a pas arrosé et puis sinon on se
nourrir pourrait des agriculteurs qui
sont dans la région est actuellement
passée à la maison si vous avez besoin
de tomate parce qu on est en
surproduction et puis art là j'ai déjà
plus d'amis et j'aurai bientôt plus de
copine parce que j'ai mis une photo
d'elle sans lui demander en fait l'écho
tourisme à vélo on part à vélo
simplement et vu qu'on a beaucoup de
pouvoir d'achat grâce au fait qu'on a
peu de charges avec la maison on peut
aller dans des 4 étoiles dormir à vélo
c'est la grande classe c des voyages qui
sont magnifiques on prend le train le
vélo ça aucun impact sur l'environnement
on mange on se régale on fait des
festins on découvre des lieux qui sont
incroyables c'est une façon de vivre les
vacances qui est juste génial et puis
aussi j'ai changé de métier j'ai quitté
un emploi bien rémunéré
bien sûr avec des perspectives
professionnelles tout à fait
intéressante pour lancer une entreprise
et puis 2 que j'ai cofondé avec un ami
jonas et voilà les gens avec qui je
travaille c'est une partie de l'équipe
qui je travaille
on fait que des projets de développement
durable plus rien d'autre on fait que ça
c'est mon activité professionnelle
vie et des gens qui sont magnifiques et
puis on utilise l'argent de l'entreprise
dans le but d'influencer positivement la
société on gagne nos vies on a des
salaires sont moins qu'avant c'est vrai
mais n'empêche on a tous les jours du
plaisir au boulot ma copine me dira
d'ailleurs si je rentrais plus tôt ce
serait bien ce que j'ai tellement de
plaisir que je vais star au boulot tout
le temps l'argent de tous nos employés
de même que marion ce retraité placés en
suisse
donc tous les projets réalisés ce genre
de projet là que vous voyez à l'écran
donc en fin de compte moi je suis
complètement sorti de l'économie pétrole
je suis complètement sorti de ces
problèmes la baule sun araw je m'en fous
la forêt amazonienne joue m'en fous
c'est plus mon problème
l'arabie saoudite font ce qu'ils veulent
je m'en tamponne j'ai une qualité de vie
qui est absolument génial et regardez
vous avez toute chose que chrome est
chaud dans la salle debout son tee shirt
moi je suis dans une veste qui étaient
fabriqués en valais en laine d'alpaga et
la laine d'alpaga qui étaient cueillis à
30 kilomètres d'ici sur les tondre un
alpaga fait que dans une vasque comme ça
on n'a jamais chaud en été et on n'a
jamais froid en hiver parce qu'on
utilise des matériaux biosourcés sans
gore-tex et 100% étanche
tout est possible partout dans chaque
domaine et il n'y a pas besoin de faire
des théories sur la mondialisation il
n'y a pas besoin d'insulter les
politiques n'y a pas besoin de passer sa
journée à vomir sur facebook surtout ce
qu'il faudrait faire
on peut simplement sortir de chez soi
prendre les bonnes décisions
vivre mieux et vivre bien et le dernier
cela que je voudrais vous dire c'est le
bonheur profond de faire cette démarche
le bonheur profond de vivre à karen
karen je pense à toi d'être heureux
d'avoir aucun impact sur l'environnement
sept milliards de personnes pourraient
tout à fait vivre comme moi avec un
niveau de vie extraordinaire est en fait
la dernière chose je crois qui manque
dans ma vie c'est que quand je vienne
dans ce genre de soirée que je dise
mais qu'est ce que vous faites pour
l'environnement bah vous soyez tous là
dire moi moi j'ai envie de te dire ce
que je fais pour l'environnement parce
que faire quelque chose pour
l'environnement c'est absolument génial
et si augmenter sa qualité de vie je
vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]